Hi, Tarot. Can you play me some song?
Thank you, Tarot. Can you play me a story for me to go to sleep?
Many years ago, in a little country house,
there once lived an old sow with three small piglets.
Thank you, Tarot. I'm very curious.
Can you tell me a new fun fact?
From trees that talk underground to fruits with secret identities,
let's explore the wonderful and wacky world of plants.
one botanically but I'm feeling like listening to some podcast today can you
help me with that hello little adventurers welcome to nature's wonders
with lily I'm lily the forest ranger's daughter thank you tarot
many years ago in a little country house there once lived an old sow with
3. Welcome to Dino Dan's Delightful Dinosaur Discovery. I'm Dino Dan, your future paleontologist host,
and today we got a Dino Might episode lined up. We're talking all about the T-Rex Time Machine
with our special guest, the time-traveling T-Rex herself, Roxy. Get ready to travel back in time.
Your body is the most incredible machine ever made. Let's explore the sub-
Hello, everyone. Welcome to our special podcast just for little explorers. I'm max your lip